der ukrainische Präsident volodimir
selenski ist heute überraschend in
Frankfurt am Main gelandet jetzt soll er
in Wiesbaden sein in Wiesbaden Erbenheim
ist das Hauptquartier der US-Truppen in
Europa vorher hatte sich der ukrainische
Präsident per Video auch zum EU-Gipfel
in Brüssel
geäußert in die Geschichte eingehen als
guter oder schlechter
Tag Europa hat starke Entscheidungen
getroffen dafür bin ich sehr dankbar und
diese Entscheidungen wurden effektiv
umgesetzt ich bin dankbar für diese
Stärke in Europa und es ist wichtig dass
Europa heute nicht jeder unentschlossen
ist niemand möchte dass
Europa als nicht verlässlich angesehen
wird oder dass es nicht in der Lage ist
Entscheidung einzutreffen liebe
Kolleginnen und
Kollegen heute wird eine Entscheidung
getroffen in Brüssel oder in
Moskau Menschen in Europa verstehen
nicht wenn Putin lächelt nach dem
Treffen in
Brüssel diese Tage habe war ich mit
vielen von ihnen in Kontakt und wir
sprechen über eine Entscheidung die
versprochen
wurde ich habe keine Gegenargumente
gehört wieso wir nicht den Plan umsetzen
sollten auf den wir uns geeinigt haben
mit ganz Europa letztes Jahr erhielt UK
die Ukraine klare Empfehlungen für die
Schritte die zu gehen sind und wir haben
alle wichtigen Gesetze
umgesetzt und wir wissen dass wir alle
verlichtungen erfüllt
haben es g einen klaren
Zeit von der
EU es wurde genau festgelegt was
erreicht werden soll und was erreicht
wurde es geht darum die Verhandlung die
beitverhandlungen mit der Ukraine zu
eröffnen und ab März dann auch einen
Ramen für die nächsten Schritte alles
ist
eindeutig es geht nicht darum was
Politiker brauchen sondern was die
Menschen tren die Menschen die
käfen die jede nach undeten
absießen es ist wichtig die
Beitrittsgespräche zu
eröffnen die Länder die in die Zukunft
blicken
möchten müssen die
Uneinigkeit in der EU zurücklassen
Europa verdient es stark zu sein stark
die Stärke Europa und die
geschlossenheittig Europa verdient es
wichtige Ents zu
treffen die Menschen in Europa müssen
wissen dass sie nicht enttäuscht werden
V 10
Jahren haben sich dieina eingesetzt für
die und ich bitte Sie heute
eines lassen Sie diese Menschen nicht im
Stich wenn niemand an Europa glau was
hält die EU dann am leben die Menschen
in Europa sehen keine Vorteile wer
Moskau von
Brüssel Unterstützung bekommt indem es
sich negativ gegenüber der Ukraine
einsetzt putin wird dies gegen sie
persönlich einsetzen und gegen ganz
Europa überlassen sie ihm diesen ersten
und
einzigeneg Jahres nicht europa muss
siegen die Abkommen müssen eingehalten
werden und die Worte müssen
zählen ja und das Thema wollen wir jetzt
vertiefen mit dem Politikwissenschaftler
Professor Thomas Jäger die Frage ist im
Prinzip die volodimir selenski hier
stellt kann sich die Ukraine weiter auf
Europa
verlassen das ist eine gute Frage Frau
Charle und die Antwort bekommen wir
jetzt denn es ist doch erstaunlich dass
es nicht gelingt Ungarn in dieser
Angelegenheit zu bewegen es dachten ja
gestern alle
das sozusagen Spiel in diese Blockade
gekommen ist als bekannt wurde dass 10
Milliarden an Geldern für die Ukraine
freigegeben werden die bisher
zurückgehalten wurden weil die Ungarn
Entschuldigung für Ungarn freigegeben
wurden weil Ungarn eben im
rechtsstaatsfragen bestimmte erforderung
Anforderungen nicht erfüllte und da
dachte man na ja äh da ist eben ein
Koppel Geschäft gemacht worden wie das
nicht unüblich ist in der Europäischen
Union dass man unterschiedliche Fragen
miteinander verbindet äh und sich dann
auf dem Weg fortbewegt aber äh der
ungarische Ministerpräsident hat heute
morgen gesagt nee nee sowas gab's
überhaupt nicht und deswegen müssen wir
schlicht abwarten äh ob er sich in
dieser Sache bewegt ob es ihm nur in
Anführungszeichen um
die Milliarden geht die jetzt auch noch
bei der Kommission liegen oder ob es um
eine viel prinzipiellere Frage geht
nämlich zu verhindern dass die Ukraine
Unterstützung bekommt zu verhindern dass
die Ukraine sich verteidigen kann weil
er letztlich die Interessen Russlands in
der EU vertritt das werden wir am Ende
dieses Gipfels wissen wo er hier steht
ja wird man sich vielleicht dann
entscheiden müssen also
EU-Mitgliedschaft also zumindest der
Antrag oder zumindest diese 50
Milliarden weil Kiev muss ja irgendwie
der Präsident muss den Staat ja am
laufen halten also bei die 50 Milliarden
kann äh Ungarn ja nicht blockieren äh
die könnte man auf ganz andere Art und
Weise äh aus dem Haushalt nehmen das W
wäre auch möglich das bilateral zu
machen also das kann Ungarn letztlich äh
nicht aufhalten wenn die anderen Staaten
das wollen bisher ist aber die Richtung
so gewesen dass man sagte wir wollen das
gemeinsam entscheiden und das wäre ja
auch äh der schönste Weg nur wenn man
eben feststellt der ist nicht zu gehen
dann muss man auf andere Ideen kommen
und das ist ja auch diskutiert worden
die letzten Tage ob man Ungarn wegen
seiner Verletzung der Grundwerte der EU
das Stimmrecht entzieht ob man eine
verstärkte Zusammenarbeit nach Artikel
20 macht wo Ungarn dann eben nicht dabei
ist und die Ukraine auf diese Art und
Weise unterstützt alles Ideen die man
möglicherweise zurückgestellt hat weil
es einem am liebsten wäre wenn es eben
gemeinsam gelingen würde aber wenn das
nicht gemeinsam gelingt dann stellt sich
wirk den anderen Regierungen die Frage
für wie gefährlich halten Sie diese
Situation und was unternehmen sie dann
ja Professor Thomas Jeger wir sprechen
gleich noch weiter ich sage erstmal
vielen Dank bis hierher